[Music]
well we're going to take a look at some
races
in detail and at the moment it's not
looking
too good in florida for joe biden let's
not forget that president trump
won back in 2016. he won all 29
electoral college votes as we can see
there 86
of the votes counted and president trump
is ahead at the moment
so we could be getting a result from
there pretty soon
also we're going to be keeping a look at
ohio 2.
that's another swing state 18 electoral
college votes at the moment joe biden
is ahead against president trump but of
course just one percent of votes are
counted at the moment
and texas which has traditionally been a
republican state the democrats were
hoping to flip that
to a democrat state it's a big one 38
electoral college votes traditionally as
i said
republican at the moment it keeps going
from joe biden back to donald trump and
as we see there
27 of the votes in joe biden is ahead at
the moment but of course
plenty more votes to be counted in that
state so let's take a look at how things
are shaping up
at the moment we can already see that
some of those states that we're
almost expecting to go to the republican
candidate at president trump of course
alabama mississippi south carolina
tennessee
kentucky west virginia and oklahoma at
the moment
we're seeing that some states have
already gone not also not a shock to joe
biden places like illinois
vermont then the states up in the
northeast like massachusetts rhode
island connecticut
virginia to new jersey but we're keeping
our eye on those swing states
pennsylvania ohio north carolina there
were some problems in
north carolina with voting and they've
actually extended the voting in fact it
closed just a few minutes ago
in that state but like i said we're
keeping our eyes
firmly fixed on florida at the moment to
see
what is happening there because it's
really tight and at the moment
joe biden has 85 of those college
electoral votes
president trump has 55 they need to get
to that
wonderful number of 270 at least and
we'll be keeping you up to date of
course now
back to leyla with me here still arun
chowdhury and william
gluecroft william could we really see
president trump
not concede and and what would what
would happen
i think the big question is to answer
that
uh how much might one candidate or the
other
win by and how soon will we know it and
how much time goes by we'll also decide
we'll also determine
how much time the trump campaign as
they've said they will will so doubt
into the credibility of these results i
think it'll be interesting you know
if we see a big biden or a certain biden
win tonight
if trump will say no no we need to wait
for all the votes to be counted which
would of course contradict
what he said earlier which was he
basically wants a decision tonight
based on whatever votes are in tonight
um
i think we can definitely be pretty sure
that there's going to be
court challenges on both sides in many
of the swing states we could be seeing a
florida 2000 on steroids situation where
what we saw in florida being the account
being challenged going all the way up to
the supreme court which is now a 6-3
in favor of conservatives three of those
judges are donald trump's picks
we could see that in multiple states i
think the
the real extreme dark scenario of
violence of unrest i think
we're still very far away away from i
think we should be very careful not to
be putting that
idea into viewers minds to sort of
create
a self-fulfilling prophecy because i
think we're very far from that
now both sides are already lawyering up
i mean that's already underway so there
will be
legal issues to be fought over could we
see irun a
long dragged out post-election process
absolutely and i think it will play out
like a million floridas you know like a
million hanging chads
it'll be you know preventing people from
counting which is sort of the classic
way these things have happened whether
it's lbj
or whether it's uh george w bush when
elections are sort of shady like this
it's not that
things are counted wrong it's that a
court asks people to stop
counting something we have no legal
reason to recount this or to count these
in the first place
and so i think keep an eye on these kind
of cases yeah right
that gap will really matter you know if
if if it's a biden blowout
it might not matter if trump concedes or
not it'll be clear and much like the
coronavirus he just won't be able to
deny the facts of that could be a couple
of counties here in pennsylvania exactly
but if it's close that concession will
be important